you
the key message of the book on power I
think there are really several messages
the first message is that people need to
understand the game that they're in and
they understand organizational dynamics
and how and why people succeed and how
and why people often get there is their
career is derailed and I don't think
you're going to find much of this in the
traditional leadership literature which
is very much in many instances how
people want to believe I want you to
think that they behaved on their rise to
the top or a scout like list of
characteristics that people are supposed
to have but really ignore I think the
organizational realities and the
trade-offs
I think the second reason why people
ought to be attentive pay attention to
this book is because power leads to a
number of good things number one it can
be monetized number two it actually
leads to longer life people who were
actually in control of their jobs in
their situation live longer controlling
for all kinds of physiological factors
and number three if you're really going
to do if you're going to make important
social change if you're going to really
make a difference in the world you need
to understand how to build an exercise
influence and mobilize that influence to
get things done
what do I hope to accomplish I hope but
I really hope to accomplish is that
people will we'll learn about the
sources of power the uses of power how
to become more powerful themselves and
they will then be less like victims as
they face an organizational world which
over the last decades has not been a
very benign world I mean you know eight
and a half million people have lost
their jobs Partners have been thrown out
of venture capital firms partners have
been thrown out of law firms partners
have been thrown out of management
accounting firms and in each of these
instances I would hope that people would
learn how to hold on to power and to and
to have power in a way so that they
never have to leave a job unless they
want to that's one of the objectives I
set for my class never having to leave a
position unless it's unless it's on your
choice and so I would hope that people
would learn how about power dynamics in
a way that would permit them to become
more effective organizational survivors
I was inspired to write this book by the
30 years for 30 plus years now that I've
taught this course to our MBA students
to our Sloan students - and to
executives literally all over the world
and what is really clear to me is that
people really need this material but it
also makes them uncomfortable and and so
therefore we needed to write it in a way
that would really speak to the people
the intended audience or my earlier
books on power dealt with people like
Lyndon Johnson and Robert Moses and
other famous politicians and CEOs and
this book I think really makes a big
step forward because it includes
material not only on the famous but also
on people who are really frontline
employees early in their career people
from all over the world from India from
Brazil from China and and people who are
just like I hope the readers are so the
readers should be able to read this book
and say yes I can see myself doing this
because the people doing these things
are not that different from them
boy there you know I think they're lots
of stories that are very very powerful
stories one is a story an email sent to
me by a former student who said you know
I really remember the material that we
learned and it's not that hard to act on
my boss was moved into another position
so temporarily I didn't have a boss and
I use this as an opportunity to make
connections with the people higher up in
the organization and build a network and
build my visibility and I think that
really illustrates that this is not
doing something grand like you know
building the Triborough bridge but
oftentimes it's a relatively small thing
like seizing some initiative I have
another of one of my favorite stories is
marchello a Brazilian who cultivated the
press in Brazil really wrote stories for
a lot of business magazines did a lot of
things to become known in the Brazilian
press and was put on the cover of the
leading Brazilian magazine as part of an
article on the 10 up-and-coming CEOs of
the future and you know once you're
named as a CEO of the future you're
likely to be a CEO which he is and that
I think really shows you the importance
and the possibility of managing your
reputation and building an image for
yourself that can help lead you to a
much more powerful in a good place
so I think this book has I think several
differences from my earlier books on
power first as I've already alluded it
is a book which is filled with examples
of people both genders and for that
matter gay people and from a variety of
different cultures in a way that I think
the other books of not so that I hope
this book speaks to people from are in a
variety of career stages and a variety
of cultures and cultural backgrounds
because we really have tried to look at
people in a variety of different
settings and I think it is more
practical in the sense that based upon
my teaching and based upon what I see
people using it's it's designed to get
people actually moving as opposed to
having powers some kind of theoretical
exposition about this is what power is
or could be
it certainly has of course a good
measure of social science research and a
good measure of social science theory
that underlies it but it's really about
how do you use this stuff on a daily
basis to get power to keep power to deal
with competitors to overcome opposition
and setbacks so in that sense I think
it's it's a very practical hands-on but
still rigorously derived book
well the responses are number one it's
different which it is it is different
than the typical leadership literature I
think the leadership books are in many
instances works of fiction they are
stories about how CEOs would like the
world to perceive them but they have
very little to do with what the CEOs
actually did they are aspirational in
the sense of that they are I think there
are good books about how many people
believe the world should be and I agree
with that if the world were like these
many books that have been written the
world would definitely be a better place
if people would be more humanely treated
and there would be less workplace stress
and less workplace disengagement and
less workplace job satisfaction and
fewer than the 60 or 70 percent of the
people who now say the first thing they
will do when the recession is over is go
look for another job but I do think that
we need to keep in mind pretty firmly in
mind the difference between what is
normative and what is descriptive so
this is a descriptive book and it is a
book which you know is the Publishers
Weekly review said it's a tough book
it's a tough book in the sense that it
that it speaks about some of the
strategies that actually work and some
of those strategies are a little hard
they're a little aggressive they're a
little competitive and in a world in
which you know people go to a swim meet
and there are seven competitors and
seven people get ribbons you know that
may be fine for the swim meet but as I
look around I see only one CEO and one
managing partner of an accounting firm
and one managing partner of a managing
consulting firm and so people I think
really need to be ready for the
competitive world that they will face so
I get some comments that say this is a
book refreshingly truthful and some
people like to truth and then in the
words of Jack Nicholson and his famous
line from a few good men some people
don't want the truth so that's what I
had I've gotten both reactions
well if I once the publicity is over I'm
gonna go back to working on my other
research interests which are which is
much more about economic evaluation and
the economic evaluation of time and
money and how thinking about economic
evaluation changes the decisions that we
make it's very abstract and theoretical
which is kind of me